what up space fam goals i'm here from
anime up we're back at it again to
discuss the latest one piece chapter
and this just so happens to be the 1
000th
chapter of one piece and it did not
disappoint so make sure to stay tuned
for that
if you do enjoy seeing one piece reviews
on this channel and want to keep them
coming then the best thing you can do is
smash
that like button like your luffy at the
end of this chapter
if you haven't be sure to join the
nakama by subscribing and this is
crucial hit that notification bell and
select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos make this
the day you subscribe if you haven't
already and while you wait for the next
chapter to drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist where i got videos about
the supernova
the warlords the yonko and much much
more link to that is in the description
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all
before we even get into the chapter
let's just take a second to appreciate
this moment where one piece
a series we love and the most popular
manga of all time
just reached a four digit chapter count
far surpassing other long running and
famous shonen jump series like dragon
ball and naruto and honestly
it doesn't seem to be that close to a
conclusion which i'm actually happy
about the fact that a series this long
doesn't feel repetitive or drawn out
is nothing short of amazing and it shows
how skilled oda is
as a storyteller even after 1 000
chapters
i've never been more hyped about the
story
and where it's going the weekly shonen
jump cover for this week serves as the
second half of the last week's issue
and on this one you can see luffy
wearing his crown
with the number 1000 showing on it and
it's perfect because a luffy
wants to become the pirate king and b
one piece is the reigning king of manga
right now in terms of popularity so that
crown is much deserved i also again love
to see some of the other manga artists
working for shonen jump drawing a one
piece
character in their own style along with
a character of theirs
like asta and shirahoshi she is looking
very fine another great cover reminding
us to take a second and celebrate this
amazing achievement and how cool it is
that we're alive to experience it right
now
this chapter is called straw hat luffy
fitting because the series from the
beginning has always revolved around
our boy luffy and he's been getting
little screen time in the last few
chapters but that's all going to change
right now luffy is finally in front of
the stairs that will take him to the
rooftop and the three musketeers who
work under inuwarashi
have cleared the way for him luffy is as
clueless as ever calling shishili and
shishimamushi however
he does say he remembers how they all
put their lives on the line to save
rhizo he speeds on a head
thanking them and saying he'll be back
this dude is so close to coming face to
face with two yonko
and he has such a carefree smile on his
face and such a carefree attitude
you gotta love it we then jump to marco
who is carrying
zorro while queen and king are trying to
stop him and he does incredibly well
marco was whitebeard aka the strongest
man in the worlds commander
and he's holding off two of the
strongest creature
in the world's best commanders queen who
even has scientific modifications to his
neck
allowing it to extend all the more
comments on if
marco is invincible it seems like queen
despite having
ancient zone powers also has
modifications that he can use when
needed and you can bet some allow him to
release
even more plagues on his enemies but
marco is the worst matchup from queen's
viewpoint
not only is he strong with his healing
flames there is probably no plague that
can affect marco
and the next thing you know marco has
grabbed both king and queen by their
necks
and holds them as he launches zorro to
the rooftop i love marco's casual
attitude too
telling them to calm down and not to be
wet blankets it appears right now at
least that marco plans to take them both
on here or else they'll complicate the
fighting happening on the roof
we've seen plenty from queen but we can
definitely expect more from the more
mysterious king
who is after all kaido's right hand man
i feel like he will definitely get his
chance to shine
soon and i just hope it doesn't prove to
be too much for marco but the fact
remains
king is kaido's marco and throwing queen
and this will have to be a hard fight
for marco if he wants to keep them busy
then we jump to momo and yamato yamato
hands over odin's journal to momo
remarking that she thought
momo died in the burning castle for sure
and that she found a journal near the
river
at the foot of the castle it appears
someone protected it so now momo will
get to experience his father's thoughts
in life
something that brings him to tears such
a thing for this child who lost his
parents is invaluable
as they speak we see law and kit and
killer making their way to the roof
where the supernova are going to meet to
face off against the yonko
superimposed on the supernova is the
conversation between momo and yamato
where she comments that momo was born on
whitebeard's ship and that he even rode
on roger's ship
which goes on to show how tied up his
life is with
legendary dudes although we didn't get
the rox pirates flashback that many
wanted to see
we do get the past being tied into the
present here
yamato frames all of this as destiny
saying that odin and the roger pirates
predicted that 20 years later a new
generation of powerful pirates would
come to the new world
and this is that moment she thought ace
would lead them but now it seems clear
that it was actually aces brother aka
our chapter titled luffy
who was meant to do so in another ace
flashback ace let's slip
out luffy's ultimate dream in a
conversation with yamato which we know
is probably
luffy's dream to be the pirate king and
by extension the freest man in the world
he says that yamato can't laugh at him
though ace and sabo won't allow anyone
else to make fun of their little
brother's dreams
and ace gets serious saying that luffy
honestly believes that he can do it and
it's just crazy to think how far luffy
has come from the beginning being fueled
on
this whole time by that same belief it
goes to show the importance of our
beliefs and luffy is in part such a good
role model
because of his unshakeable belief in
himself even when he gets knocked down
he always gets back up yamato then cried
saying she would never laugh at such
things
and she recalls that the pirate king
gold d roger uttered the exact same
words as
luffy words that dumbfounded the great
odin even we get this interesting moment
where
ace says he'd like to drink with that
great man and luffy someday having no
idea that the great man in question is
gold d
roger the father he dislikes so much and
it's deeply ironic because he loves his
brother
more than anyone and he has no idea that
his father was probably more similar to
luffy than
anyone else it's out there but i'd like
to think that one day in the afterlife
ace will get his wish and he'll
reconcile with his father and they
along with a much older luffy who'd
already become the power king before his
death will share a drink
that would be epic or at least oda
should do it for a cover story at some
point and then we see that it was yamato
who gave ace his viewer card
ace said they would definitely meet
again but then yamato read in the papers
that he died
and that he was in fact roger's son and
that his brother was making a name for
himself as a pirate the same pirate momo
brought
again it's all coming together and
portrayed as destiny ace unfortunately
couldn't keep his promise but through
luffy who carries his will too
he is present his will excuse the
incoming pun
continues to burn in yamato luffy and
others
yamato reads something odin prophesied
and i quote
a little more than 20 years from now a
group of powerful pirates
shouldering the burden of the next era
will advance into the new world
if by any chance i have already passed
on they will be the ones to take down
kaido
and we get a truly epic panel of the
yonko both kaido and big mom facing off
against the supernova including killer
kid zorro and law who is just sitting
in the back on a rock absolutely love
law's laid back position here
he's just so damn cool but yeah it seems
that the supernova
are destined to defeat kaido and having
supernova take down a yonko
will definitely throw the established
order into chaos
and that's when all hell's going to
break loose in a sense
luffy will be freer too closer to his
goal of being the freest
because he will have proved that yonko
can't keep him down or stop him this is
so
crazy and so hype it's noteworthy that
kid mentions how people keep showing up
but they should just sit back and watch
him fight
the dude is facing off against two yonko
who are right in front of him and he
says something like that
i feel like even rappers who are known
for their bragging
in lyrics can learn something from these
braggadocious remarks we get in one
piece
i absolutely love to see it and again
you see how kit
is so so similar to luffy and his belief
in himself and both he and luffy
got destroyed by kaido once but they
didn't give up
they decided to get back up and to come
back stronger and i like that i like
that luffy even though he's pretty much
the destined pirate king and we all know
that
doesn't get things handed to him he gets
beat up but
bounces back and by doing so he
eventually makes the seemingly
impossible possible
also you might notice that kaido singles
out luffy by saying straw hat
again putting him above his fellow
famous supernova
in notoriety then we have a scene
that had to be inspired by dragon ball
we all know one piece naruto and even my
hero academia
draw a lot of inspiration from dragon
ball and goku in particular
and as i've been watching dragon ball z
again for my dragon ball version podcast
link in the description
i've noticed that goku always does this
just as luffy completely ignores
kaido and big mom to yonko and goes to
see if kinemon is alright goku does this
all the time after he joins the party he
did it when his team was fighting napa
and again when they were fighting
raccoon of the ginyu force
and he'll probably keep doing it he
completely ignores the big bad villains
who seemed impossibly strong a second
ago
completely embarrassing them in the
process and here it's so epic because
luffy is doing this not with one
but two yonko kaido mentions that luffy
dare to say something
of course he's referring to the fact
that luffy said he'd become the pirate
king
and big mom asks for an apology for
obvious reasons but he ignores them
by walking past them and what's crazy is
they let him do his own thing for a
while without attacking it's like luffy
is giving off such a powerful aura even
yonko are scared to interrupt him kaido
again asks luffy to tell them what he
thinks he'll become in front of everyone
including too yonko but luffy doesn't
get to it right away
he's not going to be bossed around by
kaido and react to him
their focus is on luffy but luffy's
focus is on kinemon
just like goku luffy arrives late so
some people
namely the red scabbards here have
already taken
serious if not mortal damage kinemon is
crying saying he can't leave things like
this or he won't be able to face odin in
the other world
kinemon begs luffy to carry out their
will
to save wano and luffy promises he will
because it is the country of his friends
a very pure and a very luffy reason
and i love it as kaido prepares to
attack luffy luffy tells law to send the
scabbards below where they'll be safer
and law follows orders again showing
that luffy is at the forefront of this
alliance
kaido goes to attack but luffy dodges we
get flashbacks building up the
importance
of this fight and everything leading up
to it everything odin the scabbards momo
and more went through the death
suffering and destruction caused by
kaido and the flames of rebellion that
nonetheless continued to burn despite
all of it
and this flame of rebellion seems to be
encapsulated in luffy's punch which
seems to burn
he lands what looks like a devastating
hit on kaido's face
this new attack is called red rock and
it leaves kaido's head seemingly burning
as he hits the ground
big mom is clearly shocked saying kaido
what are you doing how could he just
knock you down
which suggests that this isn't just a
normal knockdown a normal getting
knocked off balance or getting caught
off guard kind of hit
you can tell that this is a different
kind of knock down by kaido's face which
looks beat up and burned and by big
mom's face which looks even more shocked
think about how these two yonko are
reacting to luffy right now who's
in turn calm cool and collected you see
a dope silhouette of luffy with his
signature straw hat and he says he's
monkey d luffy i will quote the rest
because it's so epic i will surpass
both of you i am the man who will become
the pirate king
and quote we see luffy's determined face
we are told
to the pinnacle of pirates which is
where luffy is aiming to go
and that is it the end of chapter 1
thousand the paramount war was amazing
and probably my favorite arc so far
but i don't ever remember being this
hyped
i think this has a strong chance of
becoming my new favorite arc
depending on how this goes and being
able to honestly say that after 1 000
chapters is so insane when you think
about it oda has got to be one of the
best
long-form storytellers of all time so
let me know what you thought of this
did chapter 1000 live up to the hype for
you or were you disappointed by chapter
1000
we didn't get a new gear or new crazy
reveals but i don't think we needed that
what this chapter was about was a
reminding us about what the story is
about
luffy becoming the pirate king and b
showing us how far he's come
since he first got that straw hat from
shanks in chapter 1.
it wasn't the climax of this arc as many
probably expected it to be
but rather it was setting the stage for
the climax of this arc
which is now clearly within sight i'm
happy with i gotta say and although some
of you in the comments expected the rox
pirates flashback
i think the right move was naming and
focusing the chapter on straw hat luffy
because that is what this series has
always been about at its core
by the way rock the name of luffy's new
attack is referencing a huge
mythical bird that was present in
stories about sinbad and other stories
so you gotta love how oda continues to
incorporate all of these
pirate and mythical elements into his
story in his unique ways
this symbolizes how no mythical devil
fruit user is above luffy
and it also represents freedom the
biggest theme in one piece
birds always represent freedom because
they unlike us humans
are not grounded to the earth
historically in the eyes of humans birds
do not follow the rules and are free to
go anywhere and what
birds more free than this giant and
legendary bird of prey
known as the rock it's the perfect name
for luffy's attack
everything came together in this chapter
including how luffy is pretty much
goldie roger like the parallel between
them could not be
stronger and as such it seems clear that
luffy like roger
is destined to become the next pirate
king and that is it for this one
you can drop your theories of what you
expect to happen next in the comments
thank you for watching and sharing this
historical moment where one piece hit a
four
digit chapter number with me we are
definitely blessed for getting to
experience this amazing tale together
week by week
if you did enjoy this review and want to
keep them coming the best thing you
could do is smash that like button like
luffy smash kaido's face
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell
join the nakama and make sure you select
all or you will miss
future one piece videos make this the
day you subscribe if you haven't already
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop feel free to check out my
growing one piece playlist where i got
videos about the supernova
warlords the yonko and much much more
link to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and or the one tier patrons the ones who
stand atop all clans in grata the world
acquire respect liam thompson
pate heffarethian phoenix anime 987
emperor otaku thomas jones spidey life
tinel
baked buddhist tungsten tarkis and denki
kaminari and our pro hero tier patrons
the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews anatoly kazowski
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci jessica kayla
font alicia actor bonnie parks hinokami
and water the red-haired raven florian
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games manwa freaks
deadly saint matthew cruz and anthony
schreiber thank you all
so much if you do enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel
by clicking the blue join button next to
the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed so yeah you
can support more content that way if you
prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you